a big night tonight for the clark county
school district after months and months
of contention superintendent dr jesus
jar returning to a seat for tonight's
maybe it's the regular board meeting the
board fired him in october then
rescinded that decision last month sasha
loftis joins us live with more on the
agreement made between jarrah and the
board sasha
brian and kirsten tonight's board
meeting is pretty subdued pretty
peaceful so far public comment has just
wrapped up and the board is starting on
the normal consent agenda but all eyes
are on dr jarrah tonight as this is the
first board meeting he is attending in
person since he was originally
terminated in october
we obtained this agreement between dr
jesus jarrah and the ccsd board of
trustees citing better cooperation
moving forward it did shed some light on
past conflicts saying the board will
communicate about meeting agendas only
use authority as a group not a single
trustee acting alone and discuss dr
jarrah's claims of harassment the
agreement was signed by dr jarrah board
president linda cavazos irene cepeda and
evelyn garcia morales trustee daniel
ford later released this statement
saying she was quote excluded from board
attorney meetings for purportedly
violating confidentiality
8 news now did reach out to trustee ford
directly and she confirmed that she was
excluded from the meeting with the board
and its attorney discussed this
agreement now another thing to note the
agreement states if any of the trustees
are not on board with these changes they
could face disciplinary action reporting
live tonight sasha loftis live local now